here's what would happen if we turned
deserts into farmland one third of Earth
is covered in deserts transforming
deserts into Farmland would require the
land to retain more water well you could
try a revolutionary method of mixing
very small amounts of clay into the soil
yeah Nano Clay is extremely tiny clay
particles 500 times smaller than a
single strand of hair if you put down a
layer of this clay around each particle
of sand water and nutrients would stick
the process could reduce water usage by
47 percent but it would cost you you'd
need a lot of clay and about 6.7
quadrillion liters of water for this
process it would need to be repeated
every five years it would also require a
336 trillion dollar budget so